federal authorities have initiated a
multi-state manhunt for William butcher
if anyone spots William butcher or any
of his known associates Marvin milk who
Campbell or this man please call one
eight eight eight zero cry
[Applause]
world still needs superheroes so let's
get out there let's take these
[ __ ] down we are famous no don't
you worry
daddy's home ain't you twice lucky that
I showed up
you guys [ __ ] ready rousing music
title chords cut to black welcome back
everyone it's Charlie we got a brand new
trailer for the boys season two there's
a whole bunch of footage so we'll break
it all down there's a bunch of Easter
eggs if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos will do a new Amazon giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know what your
most hyped up about for the boys season
too the season is dropping September 4th
but remember they're dropping episodes
weekly this season and there's a short
movie the boys made a short movie that
they're gonna release after the season
is done I'll explain at the end of the
video but because they are dropping
episodes weekly I will be doing weekly
Easter egg videos for all the episodes
so I'll explain that when we get closer
to the season they'll be way more
trailers before that happens too but the
whole theme of this trailer is homeland
ER in the 7 declaring open war on
butcher in the boys in the wake of the
events of season 1 Hughie killed
translucent they want to get him back
for that then butchers sent home lander
that message we're coming for you
quote/unquote packed up with his remains
buried at the bottom of the ocean so
that the deep would find it and deliver
it to homeland her for them that was
basically then throwing the gauntlet
then then finding out the star light was
going out with Hughie so homeland er has
been watching starlight so she really
has to play it safe during season 2 so
that he doesn't suspect that she's
really a boys plant but if it wasn't
clear if she is still with Hughie she is
still working with the boys informing on
what the 7 is doing and their big plans
so obviously all this footage picks up
after a big time jump at the end of
season one when homeland took butcher to
his ex-wife's house to meet his son and
see that she was still alive and hadn't
contacted him in the five years that he
believed that she was dead or missing so
if there's a big manhunt for butcher in
this trailer as they say on the news at
some point after this moment at the end
of season one it means he escapes from
homeland er in the sheer fact that there
needs to be a big manhunt for him means
that homeland er can't find him either
with all of his powers there's some
footage later of
black noir watching footage of butcher
in the boys so it sounds like at some
point black noir gets set on them and
the reason why that's an even bigger
threat now is because of that opening
scene from season two so a little while
ago I posted that scene to my channel so
I'll link it at the end of this but it's
the opening scene from season 2 episode
1 Giancarlo Esposito 'he's character
negotiating with the government
Jim Bevers character here getting supers
in the military what's the terms of that
contract going to be wall black noir is
busy taking down the super villain that
homeland helped create last season the
whole reason that convinced the military
to say yes to letting supers in I'm on
page 134 chain of command doesn't apply
to other military contractors in the
field I don't see why it should apply to
us caprese sandwich when they're in
actual combat whom exactly do your
heroes report to same person as always
me spicy chicken sworn to wrath
subheading 16 so the whole setup here is
just to let you know how powerful black
noir is and to be a kind of a funny WTF
moment like what is going on with this
bunny in that little kid obviously
that's a reference to what he does in
the comics in his comic book character
if you feel like a lot of the stuff in
the scenes in this trailer are hardcore
the stuff in the boys comic book that
they don't do is way more WTF but the
thing that they don't tell you during
the boys season 1 at least explicitly is
just because some of these superheroes
and supervillains have god-tier powers
doesn't mean that they're good at using
them so even though homeland has all
these abilities doesn't mean that he
could find butcher in the boys on the
spot it also lets you know how good
butcher in the boys are at hiding out
butcher himself is a master at
manipulating people he usually finds out
what their weaknesses are and then uses
those against them but some of the links
that he goes to and some of the methods
that he uses are just as bad is what
homeland are does so that's one of the
messages of the boys series is that
everybody is kind of terrible on both
sides everybody's doing really bad stuff
but the reason why it's so hard for the
seven to find the boys and why they need
this big manhunt is that most of the
superhero teams like the seven and storm
fronts old team payback which is a big
Marvel Avengers Easter Egg
are actually terrible at being
superheroes
because they're bad people because a lot
of them are bad people but because
they're bad at coordinating all their
powers in a fight and a lot of them
don't even know how to fully use their
abilities like homeland err knows about
most of his abilities but he doesn't
know how to use several different
abilities all at the same time there's
this big scene of the seven at a rally
there's some protesters with signs about
a superhero arms race this is all the
continuation of that superhero military
plotline from last week there was the
other trailer where Stormfront is
meeting homeland for the first time
while they're filming a commercial for
this is what it sounds like they're
trying to get the public excited about
superheroes in the military then
Homeland er just turns and pops this
military vet that's giving him the bird
like a balloon like it's no big deal
the funny way they cut this trailer too
is that home lenders having this meeting
with the rest of the seven saying let's
take them down but the way they cut it
makes it seem like he's talking about
butcher and the boys when he might just
be talking about the fake supervillains
out there that he himself helped create
like this fake threat of supervillains
around the world so he just lets you
know that every member of the seven
isn't in on the secret and what's really
going on behind the scenes black noir
clearly knows what's going on because of
his mission to take down this guy in the
opening scene from season two episode 1
but if it wasn't clear in terms of who
has abilities around the world where do
superheroes come from from international
countries outside the US the whole thing
within the comic book world of the boys
is that bought American are the only
people who can manufacture compound B
there are no naturally born superheroes
other than the one that was born from
homeland ur here his son that's a big
revelation but if you hear about a big
superhero from say like China or Japan
or India or some international country
it's because Vaught gave them compound v
everybody gets their powers for the most
part from compound B so there's suddenly
a bunch of supervillains popping up in a
international country the secret is is
that they came from Vaught you also see
Giancarlo Esposito 'he's character at
their meeting here he was still Wells
boss last season now he's just taking
over management duties now that they're
going to be in the military like in that
opening scene where he's talking to Jim
beavers character the funny thing about
him too in real life but he's just
blowing a big time obviously he was
amazing during Breaking Bad and better
call Saul but he's also the main villain
on the mandalorian right now too
he'll be really big during the
mandalorian season 2 which is coming out
right after the boys season 2 episodes
air so if you're a big fan of him you're
gonna see a bunch of him later this year
his big storyline now is getting supers
in the military but then also getting
them in the White House and which is
basically a metaphor for getting
superheroes to take over the government
eventually that's a much bigger plot
within the boys comic book so they might
cover that in future seasons this season
is all about continuing that military
plotline bringing storm front onto the
team and dealing with the retaliation
from the seven against the boys I love
the boys freaking out about being famous
on television like holy crap the world
is after us now but this is also kind of
cool there's a bunch of footage of
butcher coming back just tearing through
a bunch of superheroes and regular
people kicking everyone's butts the line
about daddy's home is probably a
reference to him returning after being
on the DL escaping from homeland or like
he really has to go off the grid so that
homeland er can't find him the whole
thing with the boys short movie that
they just announced for season 2 is that
it's gonna be all about butcher and what
he was doing between the events of
season 1 in season 2 so they say that
there was a bunch of extra stuff for his
storyline that they shot for season 2
that they didn't have room for in the
actual episodes so this straight-up just
turned it into a separate movie that's
gonna air after the boy is season 2
finale drops I'm assuming just the week
after that so what will happen is is
when they start airing episodes and I
start doing Easter Egg videos I'll just
remind people about that short movie so
just think of it as some really cool
bonus content hopefully they'll do that
in future seasons because it does take
them a while to make new episodes so
it's just something cool to sort of tide
you over some extra content I really
love the footage of homeland err trying
to teach his son how to fly by just
pushing him off the roof a butcher's
wife's house like there you go kid let
her rip classic 80s dad move like
teaching your son how to swim by just
pushing him in the pool letting him flop
around and almost drown there hasn't
been a ton more footage of homeland err
with his son but obviously this takes
place relatively soon after the events
at the end of season 1 but we don't know
exactly when this happens during the
episodes I'm really glad to get
confirmation that storm front has all of
her comic book superpowers - they
implied during the livestream that they
did a while ago that she's got some
psychic abilities and she's some sort of
social media maven but they didn't say a
lot about her
comic book abilities this trailer just
clarifies some of that there's a couple
of cool fight scenes that she has during
this to using her powers if you haven't
read the boys comic book stormfront is
meant to be a parody of Shazam at DC but
also Thor at Marvel so she can fly she
has lightning based abilities
she's also super strong in the comics I
don't know if she has super strength on
the TV show - I'm assuming she has at
least a little bit of super strength
I think she's basically supposed to be a
foil for homeland err this season there
were a bunch of other big trailers and
some big news that dropped in the Marvel
DC world so I'll try to do videos for
everything and post all your big
questions in the comments below I'll try
to address that in my future boys videos
but like I said they'll be more trailers
and promos that they'll drop for this
before the season starts in September
everyone click here for that other brand
new footage from the boys season - and
click here for that deleted scene of
Michael Keaton's Batman from crisis on
Infinite Earths thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you